hey guys Ryan the righteousness over
here sitting next to Dan the Cowardly
sniper [ __ ] we're gonna check out this
trailer day called Wolfenstein the old
blood announcement trailer now if I
don't anything about Wolfenstein which
is plenty mm-hmm it's a good game yeah
yep you shoot Nazis that mmm-hmm I know
that has really learned a knowledge
about games why do you think I have a
gaming hat cuz I I know what I'm talking
about
definitely shooting Nazis ain't nothing
like it racist keyword dick still racist
they were people too yeah they just
deserve to die Wolfenstein Wolfenstein
beshte that's good that's good
people photography when a general debt
says that tenants is keeping the folder
mentioned in your mission briefing at a
base of operations this folder contains
the location of debt sets compound will
be our last chance basket
how fun this is great I've got a plan
break into the key Nachi in there yes
nice oh my god Nazis oh dude
how many goddamn Nazis are there
you
you
that's like around the corner I love it
that looks great Oh oh yes please
who's that sawed-off shotgun no no who
was the person I don't know some dude on
fire and he was in a rush to shoot yeah
good - look if a burning Nazi bailed out
it was starting to get up I can burp
Anik - I just think you know you just
have to dodge him and then [ __ ] the
guy dies eventually he's a burning not
Nazis have a special ability to resist
fire burns just a little bit longer than
the human beat that we were gonna go pro
Nazi joke for a second and I was like
territory I won't go into I'm really up
to date with my games you know I was
recently in Goldeneye 964 and I was
thinking about this game and going this
is like an updated Goldeneye exactly
that's a good dude that's exactly what I
was thinking like I have the violent
version of gold it's like you get out of
my head you're just [ __ ] up Nazis
that's so fun it's like inglorious
bastards brought to a video game dude
the frickin pipe in the neck oh yeah
dude you get it really you don't just
shoot them you could like you really get
to [ __ ] kill something you're really
gonna go to town on some Nazis like if
hatred gameplay was like that but when
Nazis that would be a fun game I'm not
touching that
hey trade people I'm not I'm not to
choose I already have an idea for a
sequel oh god it involves young people
but let's let's wait on the youth topic
okay trust me it's an edgy game where
are we going I haven't seen nothing but
hatred guys if you're watching I have
sequel ideas for you yeah the game looks
like a total blast I'm gonna totally
play it I love the old-school 1930s 40s
vibe of like this cinema kind of that
was so brilliant it makes you want to
play because it's establishing the tone
that they want you to feel when you're
playing which is you're having a fun
time killing Nazis see you know I think
it's like you know that World War 2 sort
of mentality where it's just like we're
going overseas and where can I get those
Nazis yeah that's what I wouldn't sound
that sounded like back then yeah that's
great thank you hey boss that was great
you did a good job man thanks brah to
you huh
big there right hey what do you say we
go down to speakeasy and get some
bootleg alcohol ha sounds like a good
idea Dan yeah prohibition was known
around that time thanks for saying the
trailer was out but if you needed the
channel you know what you can do I
haven't done this in a while
yeah I'm pointing to the subscribe
button above my head no holy crap
there's and Dan has one by his crotch oh
hey and we have an Instagram Twitter and
Facebook yeah check it out
Torben burner hello Torben congrats with
the 80,000 followers only like 5,000
warhead right now that is a great number
and well deserved yeah I think we should
get more though thanks for a great
Channel great perfect what is your
thought about the Oscars who the [ __ ]
really cares
Torben from Denmark yeah my thought
about the Oscars is um I don't give a
[ __ ] it doesn't affect my opinion of
things Jake Gyllenhaal should have
gotten Amin ated for Nightcrawler he got
Oscars look like that's what I mean the
Oscar snubs are what get to me the most
that's true like the lego movie wasn't
even on yeah that's why I'm nervous it's
just I don't believe the Oscars are
powerful any more or less they used to
be like no one even really gives a [ __ ]
about the Oscars anymore it doesn't mean
you know you see your best say it sounds
like you like your best friend just like
maybe changes he's not [ __ ] save
anymore it's like whatever wins
it's like comic book movies don't get
Oscar attention yes and I think
sometimes the comic book movies are
better than a lot of films I'm ticket
nominate I thought the Avengers was
[ __ ] eBay's an epic character fun
movie experience
where's the [ __ ] Oscar consideration
for that [ __ ] I don't know just a
billion dollars they took oh but Dark
Knight was another one that you're upset
about so yeah like I mean Heath Ledger
did win the auction lease I think
everyone's entitled to their own opinion
and I think if you just obey the Oscars
I think it's silly it is a lot of
politics that plays into it but yeah
because that's why the same type of
movies usually an omen yeah in the same
type of performances I prefer a category
words everyone gets
shoes there should be like a our show
where people get to choose mmm
work I'm bad I don't know a like the
people should have like a choice like
wonder if there was a boating system in
which people would say what their
favorite movie of the year was and then
we would have a show called
audience Awards crushed it
it's got liberation it's double a tie
double a what about double P double P
double penetration Oh that's read torben
burner there's your answer about my
opinion nothing else also David